hi I'm Nick butcher an engineer on the
Android developer relations team and I'm
here today with a design by to talk to
you about the fundamentals of responsive
design and how to employ them in your
Android application design so Android is
not a one-size-fits-all OS it comes in
many different sizes and shapes from
small phones to large tablets TVs and
beyond the great news is that Android
has been built from the ground up to
embrace this variety and give you tools
in order to deal with it so from the
very beginnings Android has allowed you
to scale your user interface up and down
between different devices the problem is
that scaling approaches will only get
you so far so I'm going to take you
through some of the common pitfalls we
see with this and relying on scaling
approaches and then I'm going to go
through some alternative ways of dealing
with this so the first problem we see
commonly is one of having an excessive
line lengths so in this application the
text and images are running the full
width of the devices screen on a smaller
phone size device this might be fine but
as you get beyond a certain size this
becomes uncomfortable when you
especially look when you're looking at
line lengths of text you want to be
aiming for between 45 and 75 characters
of text in order to maintain a
comfortable reading experience the user
can easily scan across it in this
application where you can see that this
is clearly exceeding that the next
problem we commonly see is one of
unbalanced content so in this example we
can see there's a lot of content
clustered up in the top left of the
screen and then leaving huge amounts of
whitespace across the rest of the screen
this leads to a very kind of unbalanced
feeling which makes your application
feel completely unoptimized for this
device and the last problem we commonly
see is more of a missed opportunity
almost of not making the best use of the
real-estate available to you so in this
example we might have an application
which shows many photos as we can see
that these tiny little thumbnails all
grouped over to one side
it really is a shame not to make the use
of these beautiful big screens and when
all this extra real estate when it is
available to you and so you want to be
avoiding this so those are some of the
common pitfalls we see in relying on
scaling approaches and the answer to
dealing with these problems really is to
adopt a responsive mobile design to
respond to the devices and
characteristics so here are three
techniques you can use in order to do
this so the first technique is simply
one of combination this is if you have
an extra room combining things from
different screens into a single screen
in order to make up to fill up the space
so in this example we've got a typical
master detail view which on a phone
would be on two separate screens so
clicking through from a list item for
example might show subsequent details on
the larger device with sufficient width
we might show both of these things at
once and this will avoid the problem
having those excessive line lengths and
make better use of the screen real
estate
the second technique is one the we call
macro reflow so this is taking the major
building blocks of your application and
reflowing them or rearranging them on
screen in order to make better use of
the space so in this example we simply
moved something like a large header
image and a body text instead of being
vertically stacked above each other to
be horizontally stacked next to each
other so we'll give the image more space
to kind of to show off on with the
larger amount of screen real estate as
well as avoiding those excessive line
lengths and when it's in a landscape
device so this is not only useful for
different size devices you can also use
this kind of trick when changing on the
same device between different
orientations and the last technique I
want to go through is something we call
micro reflow and so this technique
really focuses on the individual blocks
within your design and it delegates
responsibilities to those individual
blocks to optimize themselves given a
certain amount of space so a couple
examples of doing that on there on the
left here we have a list type
application which given sufficient space
might lead to those excessive line
lengths or very unbalanced views so
instead of that each in
vidual listitem knows that given a
certain amount of space how to draw
itself so once it gets over a certain
size or send them out of width available
to the device and it will change its
representation instead of being a list
item like change to say a grip grid
representation so this will allow you to
have a you know fill the space better
the second example is if you can't kind
of visit it is simply no way to
introduce more content you can introduce
a margin point instead so in this form
type application on the right when we go
for beyond the phone past a certain size
when there just isn't any more content
we can show on screen we simply
introduce a margin point so it doesn't
end up being excessively long or
excessively unbalanced so those are just
a few techniques that you can employ in
your design of your applications and
over the rest of this series I'm going
to go through some dev lights which
you're going to teach developers out
there how to actually build these
layouts thanks very much